salaamu alaikum this was the only people
prophets teaching the slam reason
illogic open your heart you've never
dreamed y'all stop right here potential
miss me loud humming tada assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the Dean show where
we're here trying to help you understand
Islam and Muslims and today my next
guest is going to help us understand the
Quran the verbatim words of the creator
of the heavens and earth in Arabic we
say Allah is going to help us to
understand it better dr. Muhammad mcdo
is going to come out he's the academic
advisor for the American open university
so the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he was a teacher just like
Jesus Moses Abraham they were all
teacher teaching us how to get close to
God so we can't do it according to our
own desires God Almighty he sends the
guidance and the guidance today is the
qu'ran so let's talk to this man so he
can help us understand this a little
better when we come back here on the
Dean show don't go nowhere Allah there's
only one
is his messenger Allah Allah Allah
there's only one bad Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice salaam
likkle share I leaking salon wanna come
to LA here but okay please be on to you
and to you I do it as well how's it
going it's good to have it back here on
the D show kymberlee like you're
traveling you're all over the world
educating the people thank you you're
traveling as well come do a lot whew I'm
glad to have you and inshallah we're
going to keep having you back here so we
can enjoy and pick your brain and
everyone can benefit Muslims and
non-muslims of light shadow and that's
what we're talking about the verbatim
word of God Almighty the Quran so we
want to know this is sent down as an
instruction manual guidance not just for
Muslims but for none for all of mankind
let's talk about this guidance the Quran
please look first of all you know that
it's the final message that's it no more
to come no more to come so if it is the
final message it will never address a
certain people or certain nation or
certain race it should address all human
beings and therefore it is the final
message that addresses all human beings
fair enough otherwise if it addresses
some specific people definitely there
will be effect negative effect on the
others and that's why you find the Quran
that Almighty Allah addresses people and
I beginning saying this statement oh you
people yeah you are NASA or ya un ladina
a minus or ya un Karen's a la spinetta
Hilah in the beginning of many verses
addresses using these phrases oh you
people so this address is to all human
beings and some verses address for you
those who believe and some address some
verses address specifically the people
who don't believe even the people who
don't believe
in the quran allah subhana allah
addresses that he's talking to them also
absolutely so something specific for the
disbeliever something specific for the
believers are something general for all
mankind this is how the Quran you can
read it as easy as this and of course
they're sometimes individual cases like
yeah you hadna be a la sparkle and
dresses muhammad particularly and he
would say that yeah you under bo you the
prophet of allah span or dad but when we
talk to general people he would take one
of these beginning which tells you that
this is absolutely a book for every one
for all humanity is not just for the
Muslims and therefore what you expect
you expect that it gives and provides
guidance for all mankind I'll give you
one example that for example a common
issue among all the people in the world
is that they are looking for the truth
something yes keeps nagging on their
brain what is going on who is the true
God people want to know how people want
to know there's something read it in all
of us like a spiritual chip something as
yearning that is in nature because this
is the natural chip yeah that Allah span
over to Hyla created people with this is
we call it fit Oh Finn lost planet Allah
created all people with this natural
chip they are pre-programmed to worship
Allah spinal tap but it is the society
around them it is their parents it is
the school's it is the media that would
make impact on them and it changed this
chip and reproof change the programming
and reprogram this chip again and they
were therefore they've changed after
some time some people discover that no
no no their original nature says
something different and from there they
start looking for the truth so is that
kind of when you get to your insight is
telling you just good old common sense
along with this that when the truth
comes you recognize it absolutely
because a lot gave every human being the
ability to distinguish between the truth
and the falsehood
but the more people would acquire
falsehood in their life because of the
environment and the negative effect on
them the more this weakens down and
that's why one hour one roll of the
Quran that it reminds people of the
truth so that people would go back to it
so 11 job of the Quran and one job of
the good muslims is that they remind
each other and the quran keeps reminding
us that's why you'll find some verses in
the Quran are repeated in different
contexts because it's a reminder for us
10th Kira has a lost planet anaconda to
the Quran yesterday or last time we
talked about the Quran is at its
guidance and another definition of the
Quran it is a reminder as well it
reminds people of their roots of the
original nature of the truth so this
Quran keeps doing this one one example
of this yes is a chapter called chapter
number 112 chapter called le loss it's
very short chapter it has just four
verses or 4i at these four ayotte are I
think guidance for people a las 10 dolla
out of his murse and out of his guidance
he gave these verses as criteria for
anyone to use to check whether the god
he or she worships is the true God or a
false ago tell us what is this yes verse
you're talking about yet it's called
sorta loss how would you be laying in
the Shaitaan regime a long handle alamos
warm and let me le duela muted well I'm
here to Lungu for one a handle on who
allah had a loss Hamid let me a lead
while I'm unit well a me a koala who
cook one add the meaning which break it
down first yes first Allah subhana Allah
is telling muhammad peace be upon him
tell people teach people tell them that
the true God is the one who has this
quality he
I had the word I had in Arabic language
has a very simple meaning which is one
and almost every Muslim knows that and
it means also unique so uniquely want
absolutely uniquely one in each of his
qualities now let's just digress for a
certain salute this is something simple
uniquely want very very good you don't
split them up now absolutely then you do
it like a three-piece suit where you got
you know a shirt a tie and like you got
the jacket yeah some people do this yeah
tell us some people say look we believe
in one but they say God is a Trinity
okay what does it say about this
absolutely when at the end of this
explanation everybody will understand
okay yeah so here the effect of the word
unique Allah had here it's very so Allah
is unique yeah ok now I ask myself is
the God that I worship unique in other
words nobody else is similar to him ok
let's say some of the qualities of
Almighty Allah will say that Allah is
the all healing and each one of us will
say that we hear and we listen
absolutely but the way that Allah here's
is one hundred percent unique different
from other people here give me let me
give you an example and we will come
after break be right back on the danger
all of the profits would have been
labeled Muslims because this essential
message was the same as submissions this
is God talking to you how can I stand
behind the pulpit and Sunday morning and
preach a sermon that I knew was at
variance with the actual taproot of
Christianity so tell us shake continue
on talking about these chappies
pseudo-class give a damn word of God the
correct yes we were talking about this
quality that he is unique and we
selected one attribute of a las plantas
is all-hearing yeah somebody would claim
that we here of course we hear and we
listened but this is not the way that
Almighty Allah here's a list for example
I hear you while you are talking you're
hearing me and I cannot hear three or
four or five people talking to each
other at the same time I can only focus
on one and this is not the case with
Almighty Allah if there is seven billion
human beings on the earth and all of
them are talking to each other and all
of them are talking to each other at the
same time with all these hundreds of
languages that human beings speak Allah
listens to them and hears them all the
time at the same time and nobody else
has this unique quality human being
doesn't do that a gin doesn't do that
and animal doesn't do that a superpower
doesn't do that it's only a las panel
that's why we call them unique for
example another quality if somebody say
that ok Allah has a son somebody claims
that God has a son we tell him
absolutely no simply because the word
unique itself negates this concept if he
has a son he's no longer unique because
I have a son and i have many sins you
may have a couple of sons you may have
couples and everybody can have sentient
and
girls daughters and children here so by
having this quality meaning that God is
not unique if he has a center since it's
just this work itself is enough to guide
humanity ask yourself you can go and ask
Buddha or you can go and ask the idol of
the Indians or the the god of the
Christians or the Jews and and the
Muslims asking them there is one
criteria that he is unique try to apply
this to your God and see whether he's
unique or not so if right away if you
say that for instance this mighty
messenger whose beloved to our heart
jesus peace be upon salute for a person
and say he's divine he's got or the Son
of God okay how would you address
absolutely I would say now because this
the qualities of Jesus aren't the
qualities of Muhammad and are the
qualities of Moses are our own quality
he has two eyes he has to weird and it
is no longer unique every human being
looks like Jesus two eyes two ears or
nose it's not unique is listen he's no
longer you me but God wanted to
understand us okay so he came down in
the form of a human being so he can
understand that some efficiencies and he
can be more receptive to our needs were
just by saying that God wants to
understand us this is not a quality that
befits a las 10 top before because a las
planet Allah is the all-knowing he knows
everything he if he doesn't know
anything he's no longer good hey that
means this is his type of weakness yeah
so god I lost all my teeth his is the
all-knowing he knows everything so he
doesn't have to do this he doesn't have
to do this he sends messengers he sent
Jesus he said Mohammed he sent Moses he
said Abraham to guide people to teach
the people the way as you always say
that they are teachers to teach the
people how to worship Allah Spanish and
that's the line right absolutely we
don't make them divine absolutely
absolutely yeah and people who enjoys a
question if they say a question okay
Jesus is unique because he was born and
he doesn't didn't have a father is a
very good very good argument yeah we say
please just look at Adam he neither had
a father nor mother but it's still
the human being yeah so he some people
are deceived by that when they say that
Jesus doesn't have a father so this is a
miraculous thing and his father is God
so that means the one who is worthy to
be called this is Adam because Adam did
not have a father and he did not have a
mother so again you see how Islam opens
up the hearts of people to think and
reflect and ponder yeah yeah so now this
is one quality only one quality that
Allah is unique you can apply to any God
that people claim that he's God and they
worship Him and this is my advice to all
human beings this is advice of a lost
planet I'll to all of us just take these
parameter for parameters or four
criteria and apply them to the one that
you think that he's got so here the
Quran that talks to all human beings he
doesn't talk to the Muslim he talks to
everyone just take this and applied to
the idol that you worship or to the God
that you worship and see if it fits him
or not and we Muslims are very open if
it applies to anyone we will worship Him
it's very simple very simple very unique
is when you know the Trinity yeah this
will absolutely this legates the Trinity
from the very beginning because that
goes and use ours up unless it is a suit
like I said you can't do it absolutely
okay the second quality is a lot of
summit and wonderful word unfortunately
it's it's it's difficult to translate it
into any other language by just one word
because it's a concept usually when you
explain a concept you cannot explain by
another word because sometimes this
concept is that available in other
languages the word a summit means it has
two segments in it a summit means the
one who is needed and relied upon by all
his creatures this is the first segment
the second segment of it is he needs no
one of his creatures doesn't need
nothing from he doesn't need anyone we
need everything absolutely let me give
you some examples I'll explain the first
part that that he needs all his
creatures needn't
the human beings to live and to exist on
this planet they need all my deal he's
the one who created he's the one who
create oxygen for them he is the one who
created water for that so they need a
las panel Thailand on their life and the
one who provides all these is a las
panic nobody can live without a las
panel nobody can live without water
nobody can live without oxygen nobody
can live without this and this and this
without the Sun without its all lost
panelled everything the Sun the Moon the
galaxy's everything in this universe
rely upon a las run I'll need a las
problem just for a moment tell us
because for our non-muslim audience who
they've been used to hearing the word
God Lord Jesus and this has all been
intertwined together now you're saying
Allah and you associating law with
creating the Sun everything and create
who is aloft yes it said Allah is the
proper name and proper noun of Almighty
Allah of the Creator his name is Allah
as my name is mama do as your name is
Eddie and his name is Adam yeah his name
the name of the proper name of proper
noun of Allah is a lot so this is not
just an arab girl it's in his name some
people tries a moon guard and it's a
little later absolutely so all these
creatures need and rely upon Almighty
Allah Muhammad as a creature as a
creative person he relied upon a las
panthan he needed his oxygen he leadeth
the water he needed everything and this
is provided only why Allah Jesus is the
same story Omaha Morris is the same
thing everyone in this universe requires
and needs a las one cannot exist without
a las 10 de so this is the first segment
of it the second segment of it is that
Allah does not need any of it Allah does
not need Muhammad Sal Allahu Allah does
not need the Sun Allah does not need the
oxygen Allah does not need the galaxy's
Allah doesn't need anyone a lot of the
me to have a son and what does it need
to have a father a lot does it need to
have associates Allah doesn't need to
have helpers but we do it so if we
let's say for any of the messengers if
we would have got close to him maybe
just did like this cut cut cut off the
oxen this is what you mean they need
this of the odd doesn't need this that
it get so the Jesus he he need it for
sharing yours too yes inhale otherwise
he cooks it otherwise he would be that
okay and the same this thing is
applicable to Mohammed the same thing is
applicable to Jesus and the same thing
is applicable to all these seven billion
human beings so people just need to use
it is ok just thank you this is another
criterion another parameter that a las
Pantera provides to all humanity and
that's why you understand the meaning of
that the Quran is guidance for all human
beings now it gives you the parameter
you use this parameter you use these
tools and you will be guided if you use
them correctly you will be guided now I
want you to think babe is the Lord that
am worshipping is summit that's what I
explained in that he everyone needs him
let's take for example boodan let's say
for example Jesus let's take for example
Mohammed if some people worship Mohammed
which is not the case the Muslims don't
worship armored because they know that
mohamed salah salem needs a lot he just
is not somebody is just a messenger like
Jesus like Jesus absolutely yeah and
he's just turn it was the last messenger
yeah if anybody would think of this he
would know that his Buddha or any other
Idol or any other claim God really is a
true God know by just applying this and
even if you look at this that the word a
summit is embedded in the word unique
because nobody else has this quality
have you ever heard about someone who
has this quality that all the creatures
need him and he needs no one of them no
it only applies it's going to make a
little bit absolute just about us out of
your zone your box absolutely absolutely
programming going on if they just kind
of get accustomed to just going along
with what everyone else is doing without
questioning yeah I got a question yes
think just think freely
and he will be guided and that's why
Allah spittle all the time in the Quran
would ask us to think to reflect don't
take things blindly and when you do this
you will find the truth is opening up
and is coming to you any day after day
you will get into that this is just an
example of the two and then I will
continue after yes that I'll explain the
two other segment now we said that his
unique and he is summoned the one who is
needed by all the creatures and he needs
no one let's saw with that note take a
break and we'll be right back on the
Dean shell it comes to you the truth and
the attribute of the one who created you
that he's one and alone running this
universe that he doesn't become bored he
doesn't die he doesn't eat and go to the
bathroom this is not God problem cares
yeah is this doesn't make sense who was
Jesus worshipping Jesus recorded in the
Gospels despite all of the other issues
about the gospel you put those aside
with the Saints mentioned there with
Jesus worship God one
hunger so I'm like oh and welcome back
to the Dean show dr. mark do we're
talking about the surah class this is
the chapter in the car an invading word
of god this is defining who the crater
is yeah continue on please we were
linking it with that I'm giving an
example of how the Quran is mercy to all
mankind and addresses all mankind so
this is one chapter that provides all
human beings with the tools with the
parameters with the criteria that if
they use it they would be able to
distinguish if the idol of if the thing
or if the one that the worship is a true
good or not and again these can be used
by Muslims this can be used by
non-muslims my only human beings I
talked about two qualities the first
quality that he is unique you are as you
said it uniquely one and the second one
he is a summit that he is the one who is
needed and relied upon by all his
creatures and he needs no one of them
nobody the third quality is that and
what is unique about this third quality
that's its embedded in the first one as
the second one was embedded in the first
one this third one is embedded here let
me yell it he didn't beget and nor he
was begotten so God was not be gotten
had he been begotten he would have never
been unique for some people who don't
know what does this begotten to be to be
born so like father Alois so he didn't
have a father yeah God doesn't have a
father if he has a father we will say
that each one was his father yeah so
he's no longer unique so he didn't have
a father he didn't it was not born yeah
but this is a quality of human being was
Jesus sport yeah yes absolutely now you
ask yourself good talks about himself
said that I was never born right but
Jesus was born Jesus were both muhammad
was born all of them all of they were
born so they are not so they again the
ontology fit they don't qualify so
there's a qualification to be these are
disqualification these are the full
qualifications to be the true God yeah
if they apply to anyone we will
worship Him that's it that that's a very
sense it goes with what you said earlier
that fit through that natural cetera
there's a yes absolutely so he doesn't
have a father nor he has a son so he
doesn't have a father or neuro son okay
people have fathers and people have son
so if if if they don't have right if I
say that I don't have a father I don't
have a son I would be unique but this is
not the case and lost pal pal I was not
born nor did he give birth to anyone
didn't have a child so this is the third
quality which is embedded here and the
final quality which also is embedded in
the first quality says that well am I
hakuna one and there is no one who is
equal to him look at that that's deep
very deep no one is equal to Almighty
Allah now if we can apply this to
Mohammed is anybody equal to Mohammed
yes in terms of his humanity yes I'm it
had a father and had children yes people
many people prophets have Abraham had
father and had children I have a father
and with children so Mohammed is no not
not unique in that's it yeah but Allah
spano Atallah no one is equal to him in
any of his qualities yes and in fact
people are deceived by the words when we
say that Allah sees and we see
absolutely but the way a la scala
policies is different from the way we
see so that's why we say that we don't
they are not equal for example the
maximum distance that a human being can
see let me assume that it's five or ten
miles but Allah subhana Allah sees all
human beings and all creatures at the
same time does any one of the human
beings have this capacity of course not
so this is the importance of knowing
that well a mere kolo who could when had
there has never been someone who was
equal to Almighty Allah now I would
advise any person with wisdom
people of understanding to think of
these criteria and apply them between
them and themselves they don't need
anybody to judge them they just need to
take these criteria and apply them to
their God that they worship if they
apply let him or her tell us because we
are going to worship that God if these
apply to any God we will apply because
they only apply to all might a las panel
but again we thank Almighty Allah who
gave us these criteria get guided us to
the truth that's why it's it's very
difficult to shake the belief of any
Muslim because any Muslim who knows
these it's very difficult to find him
someone there's something rash largeness
because Islam is the dear of difficult
understand yeah very easy for anyone and
as you see that it addresses the deity
the average person it's not so
complicated it's very simple i can take
it in a applied yeah this is we thank
allah span or tahala for giving us this
quran which is a guidance many verses in
the quran many chapters talk about these
issues as guidance and here is one
example and I hope the viewers would
have understood what I say that enjoyed
it and I hope it's Allah they applied in
their life in order to be able to
distinguish the true God from the false
gods thank you very much dr. Ohio shall
I look forward to having you get back
Hannity show Jake Locker thank you for
sitting through another episode of the
Dean show you got to hear it here that
God is uniquely one he is independent of
all we are all dependent on him he's not
the father of no one nor as he fathered
any children and he is unique there's
nothing like the creator of the heavens
and earth so start with that step and
ask him call upon him alone to guide you
to help make things clear and tune in
here every week to the Dean show we'll
see you next time God willing until then
peace be unto you a Salaam alaikum
oh he created the universe to him belong
the heavens and the earth l11 he is the
first he's the owner Murthy he's and his
messengers to all his creatures on the
great danger of worshiping other than
Allah there is none greater
then the creator